Fleur Magick Dennis
This is my beautiful husband, his name is Locky, I call him gulirr,
which means sweetheart in our language.
Fleur Magick Dennis
And yeah he’s the love of my life.
Laurance Magick Dennis
I call her gulirr too, gulirr means life partner.
And she’s my beautiful wife and we’ve been married for over six years.
Fleur Magick Dennis
We are cultural knowledge holders and cultural leaders for our people,
so when we share things like language and song and dance and ceremony,
Fleur Magick Dennis
it's about sharing that in a context,
and all of that information is connected to country,
Fleur Magick Dennis
which includes water.
So all the different water sources and, whether it's a billabong,
Fleur Magick Dennis
which we call bilabang in our language, or whether it's a bila, a river, or a creek, dharran,
all those different places are connected to our stories and our culture.
Fleur Magick Dennis
And without country and without waterways, we can't have a culture.
Our inability to take our kids down to the creek and show them how to gather the freshwater mussels, and how to cook them up on the fire.
Fleur Magick Dennis
The inability to show our kids how to gather the edible roots.
And what to eat and then how to make sure that we sustainably manage those resources.
Fleur Magick Dennis
The inability to show our kids how to fish for the guya, the fish in the water.
And how to do things according to the local seasons.
Fleur Magick Dennis
At the moment, nothing's really, like nothing's growing. Everything's dying.
And the simple act of a father showing his son how to fish, which is a
Fleur Magick Dennis
very strong cultural thing in our culture. That can't happen anymore.